Welcome to Module 1: Introduction to Forklift Safety.
In this module, we'll cover the basics of forklift operation
and OSHA safety requirements.
Forklifts are powerful industrial vehicles that require
proper training and certification to operate safely.
OSHA standard 29 CFR 1910.178 covers all requirements
for powered industrial truck operations.
Let's begin by understanding the key components
of a forklift and their functions.
The mast is the vertical assembly that raises and lowers the load.
The forks are the horizontal prongs that support the load.
The counterweight at the rear balances the load being lifted.
Understanding these components is essential for safe operation.
Remember: Only certified operators who are at least 18 years old
are permitted to operate a forklift.
Throughout this training, we'll cover pre-operation inspections,
safe operating procedures, and hazard recognition.
By the end of this module, you'll understand the fundamental
safety principles that every forklift operator must follow.